during the holocaust Ilze cork lived in
the book and world concentration camp
with her husband she would order the
deaths of prisoners at will and even
enjoyed watching people being tortured
and killed her home was filled with
mementos made from human skin ills a
cock may have been responsible for more
deaths than your average serial killer
indeed she is considered to be one of
the most evil women that ever lived
[Music]
born with the maiden name Margaret Elsa
kala her life had humble beginnings in
Dresden Germany as a child no one could
have ever guessed that she would grow up
to be such an evil person neighbors say
that she was a friendly happy girl and
she was popular in school her father was
a laborer and her mother was a housewife
just like other german girls Ilsa would
have learned to cook and clean and take
care of a household she left school to
start working at a cigarette factory
full time when she was 15 she began
taking classes in accounting at a local
college and and a bookkeeping position
they also joined the Nazi Party very
early on most likely because she came
from a poor family
the Nazis promised the lower-class that
they could help bring Germany out of the
economic depression that they were
experiencing after World War one for
people who were poor and uneducated
fascism seems like a solution to the
country's problems it also began to
believe in the ideals of an Aryan master
race and shared their feelings of
anti-semitism she met a like-minded man
who would become her future husband Karl
Kok he was 9 years older than else
Aaron's had already gone through a
divorce from his first wife who
disagreed with his Nazi philosophies he
had a criminal record for theft and he
and his brother grew up working as
informants for the police his life of
crime was actually something that Elsa
thought was quite attractive and they
were married in 1936 after Hitler came
to power the couple were rewarded for
being early adopters of Nazism Karl went
from being a petty criminal to being
handed a position as a high-ranking SS
officer the two of them that never grown
up with any sort of wealth and they
suddenly had the opportunity to become
rich and powerful and so they took
advantage of it to its fullest extent
[Music]
before he was put in charge of a
concentration camp Karl Koch was the
warden of a prison in Berlin he would
force prisoners to puff themselves into
dog houses and eat out of bowls they
were supposed to kneel and bark when
chakra surrounds if they refused they
were beaten if a man did something wrong
hot tar was shoved up his backside the
sadistic torture was noted by the Nazis
and they fought his unique skill set
could be useful running a camp filled
with the enemies of the Third Reich Elsa
cock wasn't turned off by the brutal
reputation that her husband had in fact
she loved it and she wanted to be a part
of the process as much as her husband
did when she found out they were going
to be running a concentration camp
together she even got some practice
working at a prison camp called Saxon
housing Colin mill saqqaq well I'm just
in charge of managing the book involved
concentration camp they were there
during the construction of it the gate
to the camp
read yet M da sign which means to each
his own what they meant by this was that
everyone gets what's coming to them this
was their own personal touch to rub it
into the faces of those people who they
truly believed deserved to be treated
less than human beings book and vault
was the largest of all the Nazi
concentration camps and yet there were
no gas chambers for killing people
quickly and sufficiently this camp was
mainly there to use the prisoners as
slave labor making things that were
useful to the Third Reich prisoners at
Buchenwald were kept alive for years
which was a lot longer than as other
concentration camps in Auschwitz for
example the average lifespan was a mere
three to four months while they were
building the camp Ilsa request that
their family must live in a mansion
which was built on the same property as
the concentration camp in Nazi Germany
men and women were given set roles to
play in society the perfect German woman
was supposed to be happy to do housework
she was supposed to stay strong in the
face of adversity and always loyal to
her husband high-ranking leaders in the
Nazi Party were expected to be a good
example of this wives of SS officers
we're not expected to do the work as
much as a common German woman but Elsa
cock took her new life of luxury to the
next level she aims to have a life where
she never had to do any housework she
decided that the prisoners from the
concentration camps
would be her slaves she forced everyone
to address her as Gannett ago Frau which
is an old-fashioned term usually
reserved for ladies of nobility Ilsa
never lifted a finger to do anything
herself which made her grow bored with
her life she decided that the prisoners
should build up a huge indoor sports
arena that looked worthy of an Olympic
event this was used just so she could
practice her hobby of horseback riding
it cost over 200,000 Reichsmarks to
build today that would be about the
equivalent of a million dollars but all
Speck riding it wasn't enough to satisfy
her boredom there was a rule in the camp
that if any prisoner even looked at the
commander's wife they would be shot on
the spot
knowing this Elsa croc began dressing
provocatively on purpose she wore tight
clothing and revealed her cleavage on a
daily basis most wives of the SS
officers in the other concentration
camps never got involved with the
prisoners and we're most likely in some
sort of denial about what was going on
but Ilsa Kok she wanted to get involved
and she relished in the fact that people
were starving and dying all around her
Elsa was a buxom redhead who thought a
lot of herself witnesses say that when
her husband was away Elsa cock would
command the officers to bring out a
group of male soldiers and force them to
undress until they were completely naked
she would also strip down to a lingerie
and lay out in front of a yard of sex
starved male prisoners if any of them
even glanced at her body or
uncontrollably became aroused he was
immediately taken by the guards and shot
in the head she specifically requested
to have teenage boys working in her home
servants who lived in house say that she
would order them to bring her breakfast
in bed she would be laying in bed
wearing nothing but a nightie just like
the men in the yard if they even dared
to look at her body
it was grounds for them being killed
considering they were well teenage boys
it's very possible that some of them
simply couldn't help but get aroused
even if they hated their guts based on
these stories we can make the assumption
that she was a sexual sadist who was
aroused by the idea of inflicting pain
upon other people one of her household
servants Erik Hirsch was just 15 years
old at the time that he worked there he
said that the cock mansion was on the
edge of the camp so he was able to look
out of the window and see free people
beyond the fence watching people go
about their lives it felt
like looking at some kind of fantasy and
he often felt envious and sad wondering
why he wasn't so lucky
Ilse cock allowed him to eat two boiled
potatoes every Sunday he would carry
them back to the barracks where the
other prisoners were staying he didn't
like eating potato skins so he would
peel them off and throw them on the
grounds but once he did that several
other prisoners jumped on the peels
because they were so desperate for food
[Music]
all Nazi concentration camps had some
form of human experimentation going on
and work involved was no exception
doctors at the camp were poisoning
people with deadly chemicals in order to
find potential antidotes and they were
injecting homosexuals with concoctions
that were believed to turn them straight
soon enough teasing men was not enough
to satiate Ilsa's boredom and she wanted
to watch the doctors conduct these
experiments she saw this as an
opportunity to have a new hobby
she rode a horse through the camp and
noticed that some of the prisoners had
really interesting tattoos she
approached one of the camp doctors Erik
vogner and suggested that he should
conduct a study to see if tattoos had
any correlation to criminal behavior
technically dr. vogner should have never
said yes because it was against protocol
but he agreed to do it during these
tests people were killed and their
bodies were taken away to be dissected
so that Elsa could keep their skin I
also began riding a horse around the
camp commanding men to stop what they
were doing and strip she would walk
through the lines of naked men sizing
them up and examining their bodies but
the ones with what she regarded as the
best tattoos were selected for the
medical trial and they were killed their
skin was used to cover her lampshades
knife sheaths and book covers she saw
this as an opportunity to come up with
some original Christmas gifts and
commanded a group of Jewish prisoners to
do the work of creating huge quantities
of these trinkets made from human
leather during the holidays she would
send them to SS officers who were in
charge of the other concentration camps
one rumor even says that she used human
body parts all over our house like using
thumbs as light switches
according to prisoners who worked in a
house Ilsa was having affairs with both
doctor Valdemar Hoeven and deputy
commandant Hermann floor stet when Karl
Koch was asked to leave the camp his
Nazi duties she would reportedly stay
overnight to dr. havens home he was
known for conducting medical experiments
on human beings so it was just her type
when Karl Koch contracted syphilis he
ordered the execution of the orderly who
gave him his diagnosis he did not want
anyone to know the embarrassing truth
about this marriage some believed that
they had an open relationship
[Music]
in 1942 both Carl and Ilsa cakwe taken
to court for misappropriating
the funds of the Buchenwald camp and for
their over-the-top methods of torture if
we're being honest it's surprising that
it took that long for the Nazis to ask
where the money came from to build
else's horse stadiums for the lavish
lifestyle that she demanded many of the
human experiments going on at Buchenwald
were often made up on a whim by the
cocks this was not allowed the order to
begin a scientific trial would have to
have come from higher up in the Nazi
Party medical experiments using human
subjects usually had an actual goal that
would help the Third Reich for example
the experiments usually prove that
Aryans were the master race or that
disabled people were somehow subhuman
the party wanted experiments that helped
to justify the genocide that they were
conducting but torturing and killing
prisoners just to look at their tattoos
could never be justified even by the
Nazis the fact that Ilsa was the one who
convinced dr. vogner to disobey protocol
shows just how manipulative she was she
had every man in her life
wrapped around her finger and she seemed
to take no issue with ruining their
careers if it meant getting the things
she wanted after being removed from
their post a man named Herman pista took
over a book in Vault Ilsa and husband
Karl were put in jail awaiting their
trial in 1944 their cocks were finally
taken to court the Nazi judge concluded
that no matter how manipulative Ilsa may
have been the responsibilities made on
Karl at the end of the day he was the
commander after all and he should have
had the final say and both the manner of
killing in the camp as well as the use
of funds the judge suspended the charges
against ulcer and set her free
Karl however was not so lucky he was
sentenced to death for his crimes and in
1945 he was shot by a firing squad Elsa
was free to go even though her demands
had directly contributed to her
husband's death she seemed to show no
remorse and she was even able to go back
to living a normal life in Germany with
her three children that same year
American troops freed the prisoners of
Buchan vaults they invited German people
in Y&R to come inside so that they could
witness what had been going on in the
camp right next door they saw 80,000
people crammed into a space meant to
house 8,000 corpses were lying around
and
to the crematorium American soldiers
discovered a horrifying collection of
human body parts including several human
organs displayed inside of glass cases
there were shrunken heads and they found
household items that were covered in
human skin
the Allies took testimonies from
prisoners who had lived in Buchenwald
for years and when they heard the
stories of Ilsa Kok she was arrested for
crimes against humanity at the trial
Ilsa insisted that all of the objects
were made from goat skin not humans
however many of them really did have
tattoos on them further there was a
whole crew of Jewish prisoners who
testified that the entire time they
worked at the camp it was their job to
butcher human bodies and skin and make
them into these trinkets upon Elsa's
request even though there were tons of
photographs proving that all of these
objects truly did exist there was no
proof that Elsa caulk ordered these
objects to be made there was only the
testimony of witnesses and that was
considered hearsay
while she was in jail in 1947 she became
pregnant after having an affair with a
fellow German prisoner she gave birth to
her son new and was forced to give him
away after he was born in the video
footage of the trial
she looks indignant and angry without
showing a single ounce of remorse for
her part in the Holocaust the united
states military governor named general
Lucius d playe believed that there
wasn't enough physical evidence to
sentence her to death he could only give
her four years of hard labor instead and
she served her time however West Germany
was not done with her yet as soon as she
was out of prison she went on trial for
her crimes a third and final time and
she was given a life sentence there was
a particular witness dr. Morgan who
testified at all three of Elsa Cox
trials he later told the New York Times
that she was a hussy who rode horseback
in sexy underwear in front of the
prisoners and then noted down for
punishment the numbers of those who
looked at her she lay around in her
garden in front of prisoners simply
primitive but she had nothing to do with
the lampshade business and she did not
deserve such a draconian punishments she
was a victim of horror stories keep in
mind here that that was the person who
was supposed to be defending her
character Ilsa cork had four children
during her lifetime her two daughters in
one of her son's was raised in the camp
of course they were far too young to
understand the situation as a child when
a son odd Finn grew older and learns
just how much the world
hated the cock family he felt he
couldn't escape the guilt and shame and
so he killed himself her daughters they
were able to get married change their
names and try to move on with their
lives
the son that she was forced to give away
was named ooh colum he spends his entire
life being passed around to different
foster homes and he never got to
experience having a real family when he
was 19 he was working as an insurance
salesman and decided he wanted to know
his parents were he got ahold of his
birth certificate he figured out who his
mother was and read about her trial in
the newspapers after building up the
courage he visited her in prison she was
very happy to see him she rarely if ever
received any visitors since her older
son was dead and her do daughter's
estranged themselves also told you that
everything bad said about her was a
complete lie he knew that since she had
helped to run a concentration camp she
couldn't be completely innocent but he
still desperately wanted a relationship
with his mother and he loved her
unconditionally
he began visiting her once a month
rucola never pushed his mother to talk
very much about World War two and just
wanted to get to know her as a person
after a few of these visits he became
convinced that his mother could not
possibly have committed such horrific
crimes she tried to convince him to get
a lawyer to set her free but it could
not be done it was 1967 and she was 61
years old she realized that it was her
last hope to manipulate one more person
to get what she wanted and she failed so
she tied her bedsheets together in a
jail cell and she hung herself in 1971
buccola approached the New York Times to
tell his mother's version of her own
story they also told him that those damn
liberal American courts were the only
ones who did not give her a fair trial
the New York Times was eager to
demystify the lies that Elsa had told
you Cola as we mentioned earlier the
Americans actually did dismiss the
claims because of hearsay and it was the
Germans who committed her to life in
prison despite all his attempts to
publish her lies and exonerate his
mother no one was buying it who truly
was the final victim of her manipulation
so I hope you found the video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this twice a week so
hit that subscribe button and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]